New Yorkers have never seen anything
like this before a disaster relief
hospital being built in their city in
the shadow of Manhattan's skyscrapers
and on the ground where they bring their
children to play so this will be for
people suffering from burning oh yeah so
patients come from outside and I will be
coming over here tomorrow this grass has
been converted into a hospital in just
48 hours but there is no time to waste
here the intensive care unit will start
taking patients from tomorrow this is
disaster relief the medics who will
staff this are used to working in places
like hurricanes earthquakes there in
Iraq after the Battle of Mosul it is
extraordinary to think they are setting
up a field hospital like this right in
the middle of Manhattan in Central Park
of all places beds ventilators and staff
are in seriously short supply
this will help what you see behind us is
what we call respiratory care unit it's
a field hospital it has 68 beds within
it ten of those beds are ICU beds here
in this tent right behind us those will
be able to provide for the sickest
patients with ventilators and support
and management the rest of the 58 other
bets will be patients that are on oxygen
that need therapy but not quite as
severe more help has arrived by sea the
hospital ship comfort saddled past Lady
Liberty and into a city where the
freedom is now scarce she has a thousand
beds on board and will start treating
non-covered patients freeing up space in
the overstretched hospitals her arrival
is a relief and a boost for a city
fearing the worst
the death toll in New York has now shot
past a thousand and there is a long way
to go yet the governor told me that he
didn't want to predict how many lives
will eventually be lost the White House
comment Oswalt's estimates the total
death toll could be summer between a
hundred and two hundred thousand which
is a staggering finger
I mean what is your assessment all that
and what could it mean from you is
100,000 is it 200,000 look does it then
whatever the number is it's going to be
staggering the number is already
staggering all human life is a human
life we've lost over 1,000 New Yorkers
to me we're beyond staggering already
we've reached staggering and the only
only point now is do everything you can
to save every life possible that's what
this is all about New York has been
playing catch-up from day one his
advanced medical system is now being
supported by makeshift hospitals
wherever they can find space who would
have ever thought that central park
would be used for this alistair bunker
Sky News New York